quel est le sens de la vie
on est là pour une raison précise
est ce qu'il ya un but à tout ceci et
pourquoi la nourriture a meilleur goût
quand elle est dans la poubelle ça
c'était moi et là encore moi et ce petit
là aussi de nombreuses vies pour un seul
chien mais je m'emballe un peu
commençons par le commencement
pour moi tout a commencé avec un petit
garçon il s'appelait état je m'appelais
me lève et la belle miley
non je te plaît bel effet le que ce qui
ne veut là c'est le messi l'homme
quand état n'était prise qui n'est je
savais exactement quoi faire que we are
ont joué avec ce ballon tout l'après
midi et a adoré ça
parfois ils avaient juste besoin d'un
petit coup de patte c'est le chien
s'était pas faudrait peut-être apprendre
et ses chiens les bonnes manières
ce n'est pas cette toutes nos journées
ensemble ils se battent pour avoir de la
nourriture n'ont rien à manger là dedans
les années passées et je comprenais que
pour ethan et moi ça touchait à sa fin
au revoir b tu vas me manquer
et puis c'est arrivé j'étais de retour
mais j'avais pas de suis une fille c'est
bien a suffi j'avais un nouveau but
on avait encore besoin de vous et encore
et encore
j'invite chaque nouvelle vie enseigner
de nouvelles leçons palpable on s'est
pas déjà rencontré
[Musique]
ou est-ce que tu as trouvé ça toi ok
vrai au top
je vais essayer de trouver un sens à
tout ce que j'avais vu quel était le but
de mon voyage
et quel rapport avec le bacon
[Musique]
et si j'arrive à vous sentir aimée
j'aurai atteint mon but
métal pourquoi tu as toujours temps le
chien c'est ta grossesse ou quoi je
tiens c'est fou tout pour un chien ça
rigole pas assez marrant